You know I am that girl shit, bitch don't kiss and tell hello hi
hello sorry I was jamming the music and I just got a call from my my
landlord said oh the elevator people are here randomly oh they're gonna try to
get your keys and I'm like oh I've been like today this morning I like woke up
I went to my mom's house and I was just the garden not gardening I was
watering the plants and I was just blasting music just dancing around the
backyard in my parents house I should be but I saw the stream it's Johnny go
record I also have to record now strong he just gave me the go-ahead on the on
a cover I want to do so I'll probably work on that this week um so I'm just
dancing around hi it's me I'm just dancing around the backyard blasting
music and my mom has cameras in the backyard and so she messages me and
she's like what are you doing cuz I'm just dancing with AirPods in it look
like a freak I was dancing to it girl by Ali is interlude it's so freaking
catchy I love I like a little like funky like
and a it boy by baby no money he based his song off for that and then there's
a remix of them both mashed up and I'm like oh this is amazing hello hi yeah
I'm still late I'm still a little bit off like it was so weird like again my my
nerves in my body will sometimes just like spaz out I like was watching TV
last night watching Umbrella Academy I'm just sitting there my arm just starts
freaking spazzing out I won't stop just like it's like the I don't know if I
like pulled a nerve or like did something but my arm was to start twitching
and freaking out by itself and I was like I'm getting possessed um yeah my mom
caught me live on cam just dancing in the backyard and then I'm just walking
around my apartment building with a giant zucchini cuz my mom's like here's
have a zucchini and so I just have this giant zucchini and a bag full of cherry
tomatoes I can only eat so many cherry tomatoes I'm so many cherry tomatoes for
my mom's garden I didn't even get to pick them all I was watching one of my
streams the other day and I thought I had it on 1.5 speed because I didn't
realize how fast I talk I'm like I'm like am I and I checked this set in like
am I on did I actually change the speed no I just talk fast
I TG I RL you know I am that girl shh I'm getting up to change my pants
jeans shorts are uncomfy to sit in I want some sweat pants actually
I'm just a d1 yeah yeah I was scat a d1 um I also kind of wanted to talk about
why I like what I tweeted about this morning so I'll be honest you guys I'm
definitely I'm definitely been like in my head lately and just like I'm getting
I'm getting one guide man I'm getting one guy I'm not afraid to admit when I'm
getting one guy so and I need a limit I'm just like I've been I'm not getting
stuff done and I've just been going um and like like in reading stuff and I
keep like I and I was like you know what let me take a little break from cuz then
like if I limit myself from an account then I'll stop tweeting as much cuz
again I run my mouth I run it um like my outfit thank you that the the person in
it from booth has a grip on my wallet I will tell you that much but it's well
worth the money because I love all the clothes they post you and this one guy
I'm getting one guy man and I'm like like I was I literally I knew I had an
issue when I was baited into responding to a post I've long deleted it um instead
of going to my psychiatry appointment I'm like no that's not healthy that's not
I like I miss my appointment because I got baited and I'm a dumbass so we're
not doing that we're not doing that I'm gonna take a little break you poo has
nothing to do with you guys you know I love you you know I care about you you
know I just want to grab your face and smooth you um exactly and I'm just like
let me let me stop going on you know places and so I won't be looking at
certain places anymore for at least for the time being just because when I when
I'm missing things and it's not even like it's not even like I'm like super sad
it's more like I'm I like to talk and like defend myself and give context and a
bunch of other stuff and I'm just like no I'm just gonna perpetuate things if I
get baited I don't need to prove anything I'm just gonna let it go and to let
stuff go I need to not tweet so uh yeah yeah I'm gonna leave it alone I'm gonna
chill um and honestly like that has been fine like people people are saying or
there is fine it's fine it's just like I'm being spammed other places and
that's coming back one of my mutuals messaged me this morning they're like
did you see this and I'm like yeah I don't want to talk about it and that
led to me wanting to like provide context and I'm like no like what am I doing
I'm getting one guide bro I'm so dumb I always get baited yes it just provokes
and I'm just like I'm not gonna do it you guys can't see me but my arms are up
and I'm gesturing and I'm like whoo and so I'm just like because yeah like I
said I like to talk and then sometimes again I want to I want to embody Azura
Azura is unbothered flourishing post when she needs to me I just go yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and that gets me in
trouble so I'm just gonna shut the fuck up and I'm just gonna chill I'm really
the fish girl I should be a fish girl when Gen 2 comes around my rebrand I'm
gonna be a fish and me and scrawny are going to go swim in the ocean together
and we're gonna take over the world that's what we're gonna do but I wish I
wish I have my physics turned down so you guys can't see how much I'm gesturing
and moving around crops were she in her own lane I need to stay in my lane I'm
struggling with staying in my own lane so I'm gonna reel myself in we still
post pictures of the cats I'm actually probably just gonna straight up make an
account for the cats and just like pretend it's them talking and using it
be like boomie you'll be like dear Dari today I bothered my mother and I shot on
the floor like someone silly like that I'll probably make I'm been I was
planning on making an account for them I just can't think of a name all for all
of them probably like the cat Chronicles or something I don't know I can't
think of a name for all of them um but yeah like it's I think it'd be funny I
know like Shondo has it for her her cat her cat manager so I'm like oh my gosh
I should do that for my cats the cotton bum kiddies kitty bum Chronicle sounds
like something they have a news article um but yeah so like don't think that like
you guys have done anything wrong don't think that like I don't love you and I
don't want to be with you it's just that for my own sake I just need to chill out
so we're gonna play some Elden Ring this morning be sure you won't accidentally
no I'm not gonna do that yep yep and you're probably wondering CB why did you
delete the picture off of your and I'm like I I just want I just didn't feel
like leaving cuz I like to give you a little smattering and then I like to
take it away and then just I just like just make you people suffer and it's
like oh no oh I didn't she be didn't get the engagement that she wanted to
correct actually I posted it for attention it was not the attention I
ordered I didn't gain a single follower not a single one just kidding I gained
four and I'm like nah so yeah and so I'm like you know what I'm you know that
like that clip of that girl that's like she's like an ASMRtist and she's
hilarious every girl her name is though I don't think I don't know if she posts
still anymore and she's like pretending she's a an air stewardess on a plane and
she yonks their ticket away and goes thank you very much that's me right now
with anything that I post on the account it's not like you guys haven't saved it
please I know you guys still have it hi hello hi hey so I'm gonna beat Jory with
ashes today because I'm just not cool enough you know what I realize I put
ashes and I just noticed that typo but I'm gonna leave it like that I didn't
that was not intentional I didn't mean to do it but I think it's funny it works
with the context of the picture no no I swear I was literally just like I did
not it was an accident but then I remembered this thing one time
strongy posted a video and she accidentally like put a typo in it but
then it got so much engagement because people were correcting the typo and I'm
like you know what I'm gonna leave it there I gotta play the game I gotta play
the game I have an ASMR coming out later so I hope you guys look forward to it it's
me cleaning your little stinky ears and I asked strongy to give me more scripts
but then she's like oh let me know what hair wants to get and I'll get I'll get
to writing so like what um it's a grammar baiting I know people love being
elite about typos I used to be that person what would you guys like for like
ASMR like regular YouTube chill ASMR audio cuz I want to do more of those um so
yeah let me know what you guys want I'll just sit here and stare at you well I
wait for you to type I was for you doing I might put Fia on my desk I saw the
popcorn out from like five days ago when we did the watch along and I've just
been eating still popcorn
ASMR Bible we're getting head scratches cooking breakfast sleeping ASMR tarot I
don't know how I would do that Queen she be fantasy ASMR cooking breakfast well
like what sort what sort of um what sort of triggers would you want for the
cooking breakfast one positive affirmation stream I don't know what
OL stuff means sizzle ASMR Elden Ring Lore there's a there's a um YouTube
channel I think it's called like nightly something or other nightly stories or
like good night stories and it's like spelled like K N I G H T night and they
just read Elden Ring bedtime stories and like other stories for like from other
franchises and I'm like this is really nice hello beautiful sorry I've been
watching Game Grumps play project runway and there's one character goes hello
beautiful and I like how he says it hi face beautiful girl for you watermelon
thank you for the watermelon bot appreciate you retro archer what are
these a simple soothing us to sleep with mouth sound well that will get got I'm
sorry like it's hard to do like I know for a fact because I'm planning on doing
like chewing and eating sounds and mouth sounds for the the stream for the you're
my delivery driver one and I know for a fact that it'll be got and it might be
restricted and I'm fine with that I don't really care um milk yes milk dea dee
sheebie ASMR dee sheebie if you will early night what are these guys I'm
asking for serious things what took red dead redemption hey partner we gotta go
down to the city oh my god making me clean your room ASMR with wiping and
like okay so like cleaning cooking Chuck E cheese birthday ASMR I just do no I
think I'll leave a five nights at Freddy ASMR to Amy we're locked in chain to your
Brett bed while you read Elden Ring Lord that sounds like something that mercy
would do except take Elden Ring and replace it with one of her special
interests tutor ASMR with the writing sounds okay baby shower I read that as
grenade baby shower grenade reveal a some regular date a some are
Grimary wait you want me wait so in the five nights at Freddy's ASMR you would
want me to be friendly ASMR Gundam or maybe like I could actually do like just
ASMR of me just like putting together a gunpla that's actually a good idea Mr.
Brot um Harlett you need to step inside hurry Roxy is coming okay Harlett you're
doing a great job Harlett you need to vent can I do the laugh is there a laugh I
can do I could do um Melana ASMR because I can do her voice I offer you in a
cool like that's easy to do I could actually do like Melana ASMR Torrent
Har Har Har I don't know if I can do I'd have to listen to it Elden Ring ASMR
Random Ling random wait actually I could totally just like put up my microphone
and just talk about lore do you would you guys be okay with me just rambling
about ASMR Roat Lore sorry boomies like scooping in the litter box for some reason
but then he just walked away so that doesn't make any sense to me you just
stuck his front half in Doug and then walk away yeah okay I would have to
watch and so what I will do I will watch an Elden Ring lore video and then I will
just record my reaction to it afterwards of me just rambling about it
Madame I think you should also consider what you like that's a good point but
like for me like I like there's ASMR like there's I feel like I feel like the
ASMR the VTubers do is a little bit different from like actual ASMR I won't
get you wrong because I also like visual ASMR but it's hard to do visual ASMR as a
VTuber I can't just like flutter my fingers around visually for you to see
it was actually kind of hard doing it with the camera like and I don't there's
one girl I watch Pomo ASMR and she manages to do it with like her mouth down
and I'm like how does she not accidentally get her face in frame
potentially VR ceased I don't know VR chat that is nothing to do with what I'm
asking but at some point probably I can lower okay so okay I'll make a I'm gonna
add this to the list let me make a little sticky note oh my god it's Freddy
hi shabby it's fun time for D and welcome back to Elton he showed up it's
being the devil and he's appears okay let me write down ASMR ideas
um oh cuz you're talking about visual a oh okay okay oh I see what you mean I
apologize um I don't like I first of all in order for me to do 3d I need a 3d
model I need trackers and I need a better computer for that so that'll all be
things that I work for for my doughnethon so okay me rambling about ASMR
lore I probably just like rant about how much I hate Michaela I'll do cooking
breakfast for you ASMR
let's do
hmm sleeping with you ASMR
and I could just fall asleep with the I might actually take my
I need a hold on let me I'm gonna message strongy real quick before I forget cuz I
still keep forgetting to ask her
oh she's being I can't I can't bother her now she put herself on do not disturb
which I know she's trying to lock in for the recordings so I'm not gonna bother her
cuz I need I might I might what I was gonna say is I want I should I could probably drag
my 3d o to my couch and sleep on the couch and just like you guys can just get me snoring
so toxic gamer ASMR oh toxic gamer ASMR I put asthma oh my god
fairy tale okay you guys oh I like the deity one deity and then villainous I like those
okay I like these league of legends no more like CS go
someone I saw I saw uh I meant to retweet it but I think I forgot
I saw a thing on um Twitter and it was like new verbal stim just dropped and it's people who taught
like so because someone made like it was about like a Christian game and the guy was like okay
like making a joke about if you're playing a Christian game like how would he talk and so he's
like I'm going to the tree of knowledge oh I just picked the apple I'm eating the apple I've just
gained the tree I've just gained knowledge why am I naked why am I naked it was so because I talk
like that when I because I again I played a lot of CS so I used to I sometimes I'll just slip into the
okay I'm running to the earth tree we're going to the earth tree I'm fighting him I'm killing him
I'm dying I need to use my ashes all right going be hello like it's it was so
so that's not zoomer though that's not zoomer that's just that's literally how people talk when
they play FPS games when they're doing call outs and they're like I'm rushing be I'm rushing be
I'm rushing be I'm throwing an aid he's on my six he's behind you got him okay I'm pushing I'm
pushing bro push bro please push push get out of the way bro I'm gonna throw a flash flashing
flash out thank you like that's yeah the gamer callouts yeah snake snake and garden don't be
supposed to like it was but it was like since it was in the form of like like like the bible
and him doing bible callouts I was dying it was so funny still waiting for the val stream I can
just yeah I'll probably ask Mari to do that with me she'd probably love that because she wants me
to play val with her uh I'll probably see us for val for a stream you guys are gonna hate it because
you guys I don't know if you saw me play titan fall and I went into a titan fall lobby and I died
like 50 times I'm splitting the seas I'm parting the red sea the red sea is parted we're moving
through the Egyptians are on my ass the Egyptians are on our ass the Egyptians are our ass I'm
closing the sea the sea is closed oh they're all dead bro they're all dead bro they're all dead they
just died I just killed the Egyptians in the sea I got multi kill multi kill bro hat trick
listeners and oh wait so my toxic the toxic gamer ASMR I'll just be like I'm rushing B okay I got
him all right okay hold on that'll just be shit like that
yo sick wipe all dead I'm boosting boost up bro jump on me I'm boosting you boost yep did you get
him did you snipe like he's cracked he's cracked can you insult our mother why would I want to do
that just drop the third tablet of commandments fuck okay all right those I'll send those to
Strani when she's done recording um yep what do you mean he came back to life dude is hacking bro
give me up give me your up give me your up give me I'm better I'm a better offer than you give me
your fucking up I yeah I know it's a dragon lord give me your off I want to look at it
sick fuck I'm going I'm going mid I'm going mid I'm going mid I'm going mid he's one hit
he's one hit your trash uninstall uninstall see I could do that for hours it's just
this is so funny for me um okay let me let me close this I think it's some water I'm oh I totally
forgot about my gamer sops I was like I was making gamer sops and I totally forgot why I did this
I forgot okay I have some blowhole glass
never poured the water in
I have some more bazillion freaking tomatoes that my mom gave me well not she didn't give them to me
I just stole them from a garden like the little peter rabbits I am
something smells bad I can't tell what it is
did you know when you first pick a jalapeno it's not spicy you have to let it like you have to
take it off the vine and let it sit for a couple days and then it gets spicy I didn't know that
because me I remember me and my mom first had the jalapenos and were like these aren't spicy
and then I brought some home and I left them there and then I was making food and I was like oh
I haven't used these yet they're not even spicy let me just throw them in for some color and then I
was freaking dying yeah I was pretty yeah I forget that's how it works
I just got some so I just got the PR package for they didn't send me the tub so I'm gonna buy
that myself um I'm wondering if they've like forgot it or something I don't think they forgot it I
think it was it was part of the PR package for um the with a beach towel what is it called oh my
god hold on I'm gonna look it up it's actually really freaking cute the beach towel is so quality
I'm like what now I have a hot anime girl towel let me go to Twitter I'll show you guys um they also
have a wait my manager pointed something out to me there's like free shipping and stuff which is
pretty sick yeah here it is let me can I just copy and paste this into obs I wish I could do that I
can do that with canva save image save I'll show it to you guys I'm gonna shell real quick because
I actually like this product um I actually really like game resups a lot I've never even like drink
stuff like stuff like that before and the game resups is amazing so they have free worldwide
shipping oops accidentally put it in studio mode free worldwide shipping from the 6 to the 13th
so you if you get if you use my code you get free shipping so that's pretty nice worldwide
and that's pretty awesome um look I'm over here you can't see me I'm on this side right here but
I'm there in the anime girl thigh my personal favorites are the lean and uh that's it I really
just like the lean um well no I like all of them actually like there's no flavor I don't like the
mango one's really good too and the strawberry one is pretty awesome they're pretty good so if you
guys want to use my code she be for um free shipping from the 6 to the 13th that'll be pretty sick for
you how do I get rid of this okay let me remove it I love lean game resups are sugar free yeah
they are which is pretty awesome because diabetes runs in my family I can't have a lot of sugar
you're the most engagingly vile the flavor sounds the better it is
um oh it's blowhole blasts bomb
that's some good stuff
but for now it's 10 off which is pretty nice I can't believe I've I've
merged with my my face on it with my woman on my face my legs on it I'm on the cover
I'm on the cover of anime thighs mom um I want to buy two two tubs one for my mom
I mean one for me one for me and one for my dad not my mom my mom would be like what am I supposed
to do with this um she be lean arc but it's still good I still guys I still like I might not mention
it but I'm always freaking drinking it um I'm famous no it's crazy uh I still uh I gotta thank
floork for that because uh the uh floork floork was really cool and uh I think he was the one
that like put in a word for us at gamer subs about like being put on there which I think is pretty
neat what happened to my what the heck happened to my windscreen I don't know what happened
what the hell
my audio technica 2020 still kicking after so long um but yeah it's really it's really really
chill about that uh I thought it was really cool accidental ASMR what do you mean she be no
no oh for the like a lean uh let me plug my controller in and we're gonna go beat jory with
ashes but yeah I'm uh I mean I definitely we need to collab with the uh the socks agency girls
we've we've been meaning to do that just make me make time
I love uh snoozie's model oh I love her model so much that artist is really nice too I've worked
with them before for an icon oh they're so sweet and they make really good artwork um doot doot doot
where is it there you are there's olden ring I don't have it I didn't have it open I was just
staring at my own self on my my background have you tried gawk oh yeah buddy you have a whole
tub of that it's a great flavor great flavor delicious I say this more me just drinking gamer
sub say okay I'm adding that to the list I'm adding that to the list I'm adding gamers up to the
list see I'm fucking doing it on accident that's wrong with me gamer subs ASMR
I'm gonna bring fia over actually just so I can keep an eye on her because boomie's been a little
rowdy boy jory needs to die over the ashes like I like I was thinking I was gonna play yesterday
but again I wasn't feeling this I didn't play at all I literally most slept in was at the vet's
office hi yoga oh you want oh you are very wiggly today you're more wiggly than the other day I'm
impressed um actually I'm gonna use this bed because it's not as big
this that put that over here and put this up my way I'm gonna put out an uncrustable the thaw
what a thaw on a crustable
I need an uncrustable sponsor hi why did your paw like that
oh you're so wiggly that's a good sign
oh
yeah we're going to the bed you're saying hi to everybody
she squeaked when I brought her closer to the bed
boomie are you sitting like a truck driver again
and I gamer subs in an uncrustable I'm about to pop off
yeah the frostable that are defrostable the uncrustable
I was talking to Strani about doing a song cover for Halloween I don't know if I'll be able to
get it in time but I'm hoping I can because the song is very hard it's a rap song
um not gonna tell you what it is although I've said I was gonna I've said I've said
songs I was gonna cover no it's not it's not bonfire I'm not covering bonfire
are they supposed to be frozen they are but you have to unthaw them because then that's
because they're too hard to eat it's not rap god um but it's it's it's it will take a while to record
because there's so many levels to it because you got like background vocals and other vocals and
like then you got a lot of ad-libbing but it'll be so worth it I hope hi little girl you grooming
yourself I'm gonna get them beans I'm gonna get them beans I'm gonna get them beans um
it's not a doja cat song
wait where am I uh where am I
I don't remember where I am I was I know I didn't save properly
because like just shut off oh I'm at the beginning what
I'm at the beginning beginning it's not dragon force
no no I it was because when I was going to stream with the girls I um I just I just closed stream
like I mean I just closed Elden Ring because I still had I had it open while I was napping
I just and that's when they thought but I was just playing Elden Ring the entire time but it wasn't
I just need to run through this but I forget where to go okay so I um
it's my take me a while to get back
ow
almost fucking what ow where am I going
ah
and um I can't power metal oh my god you think I I can't I don't I don't have uh
uh vocals like that dementia arc literally though
game auto saves after you no no I know that so it's because it's because I inappropriately
closed it that um that it's I have to go through the dungeon again I apologize
because I just shut it off I I didn't save it properly because I was in the call
how did they hit me oh frick
oh my god she be get up
I'm gonna kill myself
ha ha ha
hello hey what's up dude
thank you for the great edits
I have a giant boogie in my nose holy crap that's huge I got it out
great start to stream
game
love the base cannon I wish it would just let me keep my lantern on
can I just jump down this way no
wait
what if I just
lost
can I no there's probably gonna be a death box around there
so yeah sweet victory from smudge bop no it's it's it's really sort of kind of related to
Halloween but uh I've I've talked about the song before but it'll be a surprise
die
I can't see I can't I'm gonna die again
how
oh my god I hate these fucking dudes
oh
oh my god
literally I'm getting fucking ganked by this guy please don't jump off I'm so scared oh Jesus Christ
no I didn't mean to turn it off hold on my eyes that you don't attack me yet
no good luck for for trying to go through all my vods which way do I go I forget
I think I think I just went this way I think I ignored that guy yeah it's not this it's this way
um yeah I gotta bring this back up hi fia yeah it's it's 100 monster by konyu and no it's not
now we get more content yeah that's it
oh
Sorry, please hold, I need to fix everything.
I didn't tap out, I accidentally kicked my thing again, but I tucked it a certain way that it shouldn't happen ever again.
I just like shoved it in between my wall.
It's probably not safe, but I locked it in place so that I can't kick it anymore.
Let me fix my microphone because it's going to sound like crap.
This is no filters on.
I'm typing in Heartless to a woman so instead of go XLR to a woman so hard.
The AI monster or JC no way, that's funny.
There's some funny AI songs.
You want some gamer subs?
I was called Fiyashibi.
When I went to the vet yesterday, I was going the wrong way.
Did you name Boomi after who I think you did?
I'm like, yeah, King of Umashu.
I'm like, and Fiyashibi is named after an Elderdring character and I'm like, I'm just a nerd.
The receptionist is just laughing at me.
I don't even think they knew what Elderdring is, but still.
No, yeah, I'm covering spooky scary skeleton sent shivers down your spine.
Yonka.
I'm sitting in the morning on the diner on the corner.
My nose is a cheat.
Yeah.
Living tombstone.
There's a, wait, there's a living tombstone version?
Is this person going to hunt me down?
Okay, they're not.
Sorry, I only know the OG because I'm a, I'm a, I'm a hipster.
Just kidding.
No, I know that one.
I just, it took me a moment to think of it.
As I sing living tombstone songs all the time, like every time I hear the word discord or
mention discord, my mind just automatically has to start singing discord.
I'm howling at the moon.
I did it in call yesterday when I was talking and when I was doing, not yesterday.
Uh, when I was in the collab.
Oh, they blow up again.
Didn't notice that.
I'm freaking went the wrong way.
I've done this before.
Never get ready to go.
Now it's still hit me.
Sheeby heal and work it on it.
I shouldn't have used that flask accidentally over healed.
I'm Ari.
I want to be Tracer.
What about little maker?
I'm already with a marker.
Big fashion, nerf fashion.
Amy sang that last night.
Hell yeah.
It seems like everybody had a good time in her, her members stream, which I'm glad for
singing some bangers.
Amy's a great singer.
Mercy's also great.
Honestly, all of us are great singers.
Me.
Not so much.
I'm okay.
Like thank God for mixing is all I'm going to say.
Azura is very good at singing.
Oh, hold on.
I'm just going to go out and die.
See, I didn't take too long to get back, you know, just like.
Let me just stand over here.
All right, go.
Go do stuff.
I'm going to die.
I just like this one rune candle.
Oh, I'm going to sit here and I'm going to heal with my one flask and I'm just going to.
Wow.
I'm dead.
That's fine.
I got to the stake America.
Like my impromptu karaoke singing.
I just know I don't have all the sacred tears.
So that's probably why like I don't, I don't get a lot.
Yeah, I was singing a lot this morning.
It's jamming.
I also, like you can see, I only have, I only have a what you're starting with that.
Come on, bro.
I'm not ready.
Oh, please.
Why do you got a teleport?
Well, I'm going to do this.
I'm going to get caught.
And then I'm going to go.
And I'm going to get caught.
And then I'm going to go over here and hide behind this thing and heal.
And then we're going to gang.
We're going to gang you after you're done.
I'll take the heat.
Ow.
No, don't use the magic.
Just, just slice them.
Just slice them.
Heal you fool.
Ah, I don't know.
I can never tell what the frick this guy teleports to do.
Stop trying to magic slice him.
Actually, you know what?
Fine.
That's maybe that'll be good for blood build up.
What?
Ah, fat man.
Why are you using the comet?
I'm getting set on fire.
Where'd he go?
Ow.
Nice, nice dodge.
Do you see his dodge?
Oh my God.
That was lovely.
I'm so proud.
God damn.
Let me just heal real quick and not fuck this up.
All right, give him, give him a little stabby stab.
Come on.
Come on, Ash.
Go get him.
No.
One hit.
Yeah.
See, I should have done that, but I was too proud.
Give me my money.
Sick.
All right.
260?
Damn.
The drops for, the drops for runes are pretty nice.
Wait, where's the, is there, I just walk past the grace.
Hi.
He's one hit.
All right.
Let's.
Are you kidding me right now?
Do I really need?
Oh, done.
Oh, my God.
Hey, what the shibbity?
Do I not have any?
What is that?
Oh, it's a vulgar bloom.
Do I not have any?
What was it called?
How many fricking runes?
All right.
It looks like I'll have to farm a little bit.
I don't like this.
It seems like a trap.
I'm pretty sure there's some flower bros around here.
I'm not really liking that.
I'm going to leave.
And I'm going to go someplace else because I don't want to lose my runes, guys.
Because you guys know I'm done.
I'll come back.
Don't worry.
I'm just going to farm.
I'm going to farm those little little guys.
Add a.
Over here.
Check the second tab.
What do you mean?
Oh, oh.
Actually.
Golden vow.
Oh, did not know that was a thing.
I didn't know.
Golden vow was a wait.
Oh, I'm at the wrong grace.
Foli airs quest.
Perhaps.
I don't mean to sit down.
I don't know why I feel like I need to sit down.
Yeah.
Why are you so funny looking?
Wait.
Give me a second.
So the frickin perfumer talisman on.
Give me this, actually.
I haven't been.
Should I keep the Godfrey icon on?
I don't really need the flame strike talisman right now.
I will put.
How hard this raise the arcane to 14.
God damn.
I'll put the charge to his.
Hi.
She she beat the gradient jewelry and killed him.
Jewelry.
Oh, wait.
No, I was going to put on the golden scarab.
I'm going to take off the charge for a second and put on the gold.
Just so I can get some more stuff.
And then I'll farm these dudes just because come on.
Yeah.
Do they get their own poison proc?
Come on.
I know you can come in here.
You've done it before.
Come on.
You will see.
You will see pussy.
Charge tevies with perfume.
Yeah, but I'm not using the perfume right now.
You guys are going to gang me when I step outside the door.
I don't like that.
Just come in.
Yes.
You.
Eenie meenie miney you.
Actually, this might take too long.
You guys only give 3K.
I swear it was more than that before.
Maybe it's just more.
And uh.
Caleb.
How many how many rooms do I need?
Hold on, sir.
Please.
Hold on.
I need 46 and I'm at 31.
I have.
I know I have ranged magic, but I won't.
I prefer to slice people up because I'm a sick fuck.
I'm a sick fuck.
Like a quick fuck.
I like my dick sucked a little bit, but.
That's what we should cover.
You're such a fucking hoe.
I love it.
I'm sorry.
I'm picturing.
I'm picturing us singing that like real air doing a group cover
of you're such a fucking hoe.
Oh, that would just be so funny to me.
Oh my God.
I just need to kill one more dude.
In the Roblox outfits.
Yeah.
Wait, wait, what are the lyrics for that?
I kind of will look it up now.
Okay.
Your boyfriend is a dork.
Make loving.
Then I.
Where is it?
I'm a sick fuck.
I like a quick fuck.
I like my dick sucked a bio sick truck.
I'll buy you some new tits.
I'll get you that nip tuck.
How you started filming the condom slipped up.
I'm a sick fuck.
I'm inappropriate.
I like hearing stories.
I like the whole shit.
I want to hear most shit.
Send me some most shit.
You trifling hoe bitch.
You're such a fuck.
It is too hard.
Let's follow behind.
She just like dancing behind me.
Just like.
I'll be a big yawn.
Squish, squish, squish, squish, squish.
Where's your paw?
They just upped her dose for her medicine.
And I think it's helping because they said that she was on too low of a dose.
And so she's already wiggling a little bit more.
Yeah.
And then she, she has her, she's on steroids.
Fia's, Fia's going to roid rage.
Gotta be honest, this song came on autoplay earlier.
Oh yeah.
Oh I didn't read the first half of that comment.
That's funny.
It came on autoplay.
I also like this song.
Um, I like the song with pink panther is in catering on his new album.
It's pretty good.
She's like, what are you doing with the song?
I'm gonna wrap up.
I'm gonna wrap up here.
Yeah.
Not his new album.
It's pretty good.
Okay, thank you.
Oh.
Um, it's called Snap My Fingers.
I was listening to that today too.
Wish that I could snap my fingers.
La la la la.
Wish that I could.
The thing is when I sing, I mimic the singer's voice, so I can get pretty high, but it doesn't
sound good when I sing for Pink Panthers.
It awaits inside.
What?
La la la.
Lil' Pomp.
She beat being Adele?
What?
Hella from the other side.
I must have called a thousand times to tell you I'm sorry for breaking your heart and
in a minute.
I don't remember the lyrics.
Gotta be more British.
Oh, I am Adele.
Oh.
Hella from the other side.
What is all these messages?
Don't let it see you.
Once you are seen, there's no escape.
It cannot even be touched.
Wait, I think I know what this is.
I think I know because I was listening to a lore video and I think I know what these
are.
There's a dude in the forest.
There's a dude here.
He's doing shit.
I think he's like the untouchable.
You can only parry them.
I don't know how to freaking parry.
What the fuck is the music?
Why are all the goats shush?
Why are they all frenzied flame eyes?
Who the fuck is this dude?
Is he the one that's...
Oh no, I know who he is too.
He's the...
Who the fuck just died?
He's the one...
I forget what weapon he has.
It's not a fist, it's something else.
Guys, stop.
Stop making me scared.
Oh.
Oh, damn, frenzied flame.
That's me up.
Ow, yeah, he's like the fists of whatever.
Yeah, the maddening hand, that's who it is.
Oh, I'm dead.
This guy just ganked me.
He's just punching the shit out of me.
Fee as a goat, sometimes in Fee-A-Me-O, she sounds like a goat.
Yeah, I'm like, what's up that date?
I'm getting absolutely rocked.
Let me change my stuff.
This is where Midra is, right?
I'm on the way to Midra.
Look at the little sheep.
I like their glowing eyes.
They look kind of pretty when they're infected with madness.
Can I summon?
Can I just abuse my summon?
Can I do good damage on him?
OK, I got the maddening hand.
I got the magic stick.
I love lamb chops, I'm scared.
Because I remember I was listening to lore about Midra the other day, so I know there's
a dude around here.
I don't remember what they look like, though.
I hear squeaky rats.
Wait, what's over there?
Oh.
Make not a sound.
Quietly await your chance.
Combat is not an option.
Oh yeah, it is one of the dudes.
Because you got a crouch in the undergrowth?
They literally give you, you got to like, ooh, because you can kill them.
They are very cool looking.
They have like bulgy eyes.
You can kill them, but you got to parry each time.
And I can't block and parry, so.
I don't know where I'm going.
I think they like slingy degushers, possibly.
Wait, can I go that way?
Here's the map.
I kind of want to fight one.
How many runes do I have?
I only have 4,000, 5,000.
I kind of want to see, hey.
Oh, frenzy.
Because yeah, they're the untouchables, and you can't.
Yeah, and you can only like, parry.
I'm maddened.
I don't know how to, ooh.
I picked up the parry dagger from the keep.
Too many warhead candies.
Bro, I think the caffeine is hitting me right now.
I'm getting a little bit jittery.
All right, let me go towards the map.
Our heads do look squishy.
Acquire me.
I don't like the squeaky rats.
You're a big one.
I do like frenzied flame.
Maybe I'll do a frenzied flame build.
Look, it's the map.
I'm the map.
I feel like if I bit one of their eyes, it would taste like some sort of sour orange candy.
Mwah.
OK, I got the abyss map.
Let's go.
Let's look.
Finally, we got everything.
Now I can see.
Hayata does eat those eyes.
That is correct.
Abandoned church.
Don't mind if I do.
Is there a scabba-dabba-do tree fragment?
Yeah, scabba-dabba-do-ba-de-dabba-de-do-da-da.
I'm a scat man.
Scabba-do-do tree.
My frenzied flame perfume bottle.
Oh, shit.
Reach out and touch grace.
I wish the status was useful on more than just NPCs.
At that point, you basically just build for the damage.
Code vein.
Oh, I've never played that.
OK, I'm just checking.
I do not have enough.
Oh.
Actually, I'm going to go real quick to the table of lost grace
because I'm going to see if I can upgrade my ash.
Although, I don't know if it really matters, but who knows.
That's not the way.
I don't know why I just automatically came to you.
But I would have liked to actually if I had a spitting stone.
Oh, I know I need a six.
It's not a five.
I need a six.
All right.
Guys, I'm scared to go in here.
There's a lot.
I'm scared.
This place is so freaking big.
Oh, my God.
Got a parry.
I can't parry.
I don't even think why I can think I can go over here
and try to fight Midra or whatever.
Wait, is this just a spooky forest?
I don't really see any like buildings in here.
Actually, wait, where were those two hippos?
There are.
Where are those two hippos?
There's two hippos.
I was I didn't kill and I said I would do them later.
Where were they?
Were they over here?
Oh, my God.
Where were they?
Does anybody know?
It was at the top of the dark like catacombs.
OK.
Carry and retaliation on a shield.
Oh, interesting.
That's pretty smart, actually.
All right, let's see if we can kill those dudes.
I'm going to sip some of my suppies.
I'm going to see if I can kill these.
And then I might end it just to end it all just
because I want to make sure I rest a little
before the holocaer stream.
Should I grab my runes?
Where the heck are they?
Yeah, I was up top here.
Hey, are you licking yourself in your sleep?
Or are you?
What's happening here?
I missed.
Come back here.
Come here.
I'll get you.
Does it not see me?
There we go.
That's just what's worked.
Narrowly missing death.
Making some stairs.
Making my way downtown.
Talking fast.
Faces past and I'm homebound.
And I need you.
And I miss you.
And now I wonder if I could fall into the sky.
Do you think time will pass me by?
Because you know I'd walk a thousand miles
so I could just fuck.
Wow, this is a lot easier on horseback.
I should have listened to y'all.
He wears his heart safety pin to his backpack.
His backpack is all that he knows.
Ow.
Cripple heart and a vow where the soul.
Oh, I accidentally aggroed the other one.
Bad.
Die, die potato.
Not today.
I think.
I need luck on you now.
Ow.
Where'd you go?
Come on, torrent.
Took a moment, he's just like, huh?
No.
Get his ass, get his ass, get his ass.
Get him.
Oh, I didn't think he'd be able to hit me.
Get his asshole, get him in the asshole.
Get him in the asshole.
Come on, torrent.
Oh, I, alright, let me heal.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Okay, cool.
Bazinga.
Pinning at the disco, it's the used.
Hey, what's, how's the song go?
Try and think of that one song.
Thirteen!
Um, how's the song go?
I don't know why I'm blanking.
Oh, well imagine, as I'm pacing the pews in a church corridor and I can't help but to hear,
no I can't help but to hear in exchanging of words.
What a beautiful wedding, what a beautiful wedding, says the bridesmaid to the waiter.
Yes, but what a shame, what a shame the poor groom's bride is a whore,
is a bielder member.
I chime in with the haven't you people ever heard of?
Closing the goddamn door, no, it's much better to face these kinds of things,
with a sense of poison rationality.
I chime in, haven't you people ever heard of?
Whoa.
Closing the goddamn door, no, it's much better to face these kinds of things,
with a sense of poison rationality.
Again!
Where is, I'm just wandering the forest.
Trying to get my runes so I don't have to keep staring at this stupid thing.
Kill the rock.
This is like the forest of, what is it called?
Oh my god, why am I blanking on my favorite movie?
Where the R-U-U-S's?
It's the fire swamp!
It's the fucking fire swamp.
You know, it would be awesome if they actually, I wouldn't be,
I would totally see Frumsoft putting the fire swamp in a game.
Bust out this thing, no, that was me blowing on the cap of my Gamer Sub's shaker.
Okay, I need to grab that and run away.
He needs to turn around.
The fire swamp.
Burning area period, every time I died,
it was when people thought it was a panic zone.
Boop, wait, is my, I think my Uncrustable is done defying.
Mmm, mmm, mmm.
No, I don't.
I do not have any of the talismans.
He didn't see me, I'm fine.
Everything is honky-dory.
Sorry, eating Uncrustable.
It's the reduced sugar wheat strawberry jelly.
Splash splash.
What? What?
Ah, how did he see me?
Flea.
I know, I usually forget I have an Uncrustable too,
because I like leave it out to thaw.
Am I safe now?
No.
I thought that was a golem against the wall.
Where are you coming from?
I just hear squeaking.
Ah, there's so many.
This is a big forest.
I touch the, oh, if I touch the plant.
What? I can't see a damn thing in this fog.
That doesn't help at all, actually.
No, thank you.
Are they doing this on purpose?
Why can I only see two feet in front of me?
Like what?
This is so weird, because it's just a line.
What?
Oh, what's this?
Madness, stop, stop trying to fucking bought me.
Me.
Stop!
I don't know where the hell a snake America is.
He is pretty fast.
Yeah, I can't call Torrent.
How far away?
Okay, they're not that far away.
All right, we gotta zoom.
Yeah, then he fucking appears behind me.
Can you stop?
I'm stuck.
I'm dead.
Goodbye, runes.
These guys are annoying.
I might have to carry in retaliation
before I go in the magical forest.
I kind of want to...
I already went to the runes.
What's up here?
I don't think I went to the top.
What's the main gauche?
This makes me...
Yeah, because you can't carry the both of them.
How do I...
Where's the road?
Is this the road?
Oh, this is the road.
Are the wolves gonna howl and drop from the sky?
No, we're not in Stormvale.
No.
What?
What the hell was that?
What the fuck was that noise?
What?
What are you doing here?
That's just...
What the hell?
Oh, I see.
That's to fight the golem.
That's cute.
I don't really need that right now.
That makes sense.
Fingering guys?
What?
Was that a...
He is so far from such a crazy range.
Am I going the right way? I am.
There it is. Is it? I don't know.
I can't really tell.
There's a lot of wolfies up here.
The Assassin's Gambit of Ash of War
also allows you to run by them without aggroing them.
Just take it on a dagger and reapply.
Interesting. Fascinating.
That's pretty smart.
Alright, let me just do a cheeky 10.
I won't go to that church though.
Let's go to the church first.
And then we'll hop back on the road.
The most fingered guy actually?
Is it the mother of fingers?
Oh, Rabbith.
We're running out of our names.
What did you do today?
I took a bath. Oh, perfect.
Contraption does not move.
That's crazy.
Come on, okay.
Never rob a Rabbith's rhubarb.
Now say that five times fast.
Why is this a bigger than it actually is?
Very interesting.
I'm assuming there's also way to cheese into here.
No? Alright.
Similar to Pokemon names, accurate.
Oh, what is this?
Well, well, well.
I need to find some fucking stupid rocks.
I know the shackle works, but the rocks are probably close.
Probably over here.
No? Sometimes it's like they're on a little hidden spot.
You might just use the shackle.
Rocks!
Rocks, where are you?
I'm probably blind.
I don't remember what the shackle looks like.
What?
I could have sworn...
Wait, why is there...
Why are these larval tears look so different from each other?
I didn't know that.
It looks like I don't have a shackle.
Ablehouch.
One from the deal.
Beast Eye.
Wait, I don't have a shackle?
I got Margaret's shackle.
When I was trying to get Moog's shackle.
Am I blind?
Shackle isn't a key item.
Oh.
Bonicula.
What would it be under then?
I'm actually super sleepy.
What's happening to me?
Do I not have it?
Maybe I just don't have one.
I could have sworn...
One tab over?
Oh, there it is.
Go.
I'm silly.
What the...
Let's try that again.
Excuse me, small deer.
Where am I supposed to land?
On either side, probably.
It's like, I can't really see...
What the hell?
Alright, after this, I'll do that later.
It's not really important right now.
I want to see what's at the top of this ridge.
Forget it.
Forget it all.
Alright.
No marionette brothers.
It's the Mario Brothers except they're marionettes.
This one just like froze.
This looks neat.
What is this place?
It looks like a giant greenhouse.
On the map.
Is there a tibia mariner here?
Because this is definitely the area
where a tibia mariner would chill.
Ooh, is a grace.
Oh, a meter.
Oh.
I see.
I wonder why there's a very random grace in here.
Oh, madame.
What? It looks like a greenhouse.
Look.
Doesn't it look like a greenhouse on the outside?
Looks like a, you know, it's pretty.
There's like glass and stuff.
I don't know.
Can I open this?
Or a cathedral?
I don't know what that is.
It's a cathedral.
Ooh.
Hello.
Who are you?
Oh, you're an actual person.
We?
Sorry, my sword's in your face.
Oh, met her.
Don't bite the...
Can we get our DLC spells?
Oh.
Thanks.
You're really chill.
What do you, what do you mean?
Spooky Woods were fine.
Thank you.
You're really kind.
Yeah? You can see it in my eyes?
I'm a fighter.
I do.
Bring the bells and get the spells.
That was a very pregnant pause.
Study sorcery.
Wow.
Ooh.
Oh, perfect. I can get retaliation from you.
Sick.
What's this one?
Miriam's vanishing.
Cool.
If only I had some fucking money.
The little boy?
There's a little boy in here?
I'm gonna kill him.
I can't see.
Where's the boy? I'm gonna kill him.
I'm gonna kill this little child.
Where's the child?
Where's the child? Give me the child.
Hand over the child. Give me the baby.
Show, show me the child.
So remember those finger ruins on your map?
Oh, okay.
Yep. So those are the...
I probably like to underground.
I don't see a little boy in here.
Give me the kid so I can kill him.
Where is he?
Check the grave outside?
Oh, so he's already dead?
That's too, too bad.
I wanted to do it myself.
There's a lot of graves.
Hello?
Why is your heart beating so fast?
I don't see anybody.
What? Are you talking?
It's wiggling near him?
What are you...
I was charging my Tamagotchi,
so I think the kid is dead.
I...
Guys, I don't see anybody.
So I'm going to get Chris Hansen
because I want to kill kids?
What's worse than a rapist?
A child!
There's a grave I can inspect?
Oh!
Okay.
He's there later?
He's already dead!
Show up and fight me!
Alright, well...
I kind of wanted a mini boss.
He's more than one kid?
I'll kill him all then.
You surprised me.
Wait, the guy on his...
This is when his boy is dead?
It was the boy with Tamagotchi all along.
I don't know where I'm going.
What's happening over here?
I'm just looping back around.
Hey.
There's so many of you here.
Why are you guys like all at this side?
Let me unlock.
Ooh, what's that over there?
Is there anything we can have?
Oh look, it's little pigs!
Oh wait, these are wolves.
I thought they were pigs.
They're weird spirit ashes?
Starlight? I fucking hate starlight shards, man.
They don't do shit.
Those wolves still aggroing on me?
Oh, yep. Sorry.
Wait, he has five kids?
Or did I kill five Tamagotchis?
I don't recall.
What are you holding?
What is that?
What are they holding?
Oh, they can use Glintstone magic?
I don't know how a
puppeteered thing
can use Glintstone magic.
Because technically,
they're not alive.
They're robots.
So I want to know more about that.
No, not robots, if you guys know what I mean.
There's another NPC in the church.
Alright, well, let's go chat with them.
Nice t-shirt, thanks.
I can't see.
What the heck?
I feel like there should be shit around here.
These bugs are just
big chilling.
Or they're dead, I can't really tell.
Okay.
Oh, it's you!
Move.
You have a really cool outfit.
What the hell? Hold on, let me just...
What?
You look pretty fucking sly.
I knew you were a woman.
Can I have your sword?
Only...
There is one thing I would say.
Count Enya's kindness as a gift.
Should you cross him,
you will sorely regret it.
Can I kill you?
There is nothing more.
Can I attack her?
I kind of want her outfit.
Does she have any important
lore or
quests?
I can get her fit in a jail.
We're in a passive zone.
Oh, I can't fucking...
You're so lucky I can't kill you right now.
I'm spamming all my buttons
to attack.
It does look like a small sauron, that's why I want it.
How do I do her quest?
Where is her jail?
Is it in the...
Can I kick this candle over?
I just want to destroy things.
Look at this fancy candle bra.
Dead.
Kill the candle.
Kill it.
I can't. Kill it.
Break everything.
Break everything in the room.
Ring some bells.
Ring it.
Or get her and her sister...
I don't care about the summons.
I'd rather get her katana
cause it looks fucking sick.
It looks like it has
the death flame or whatever the fuck on it.
I want her outfit.
She's wearing an interesting outfit.
I can't tell...
that she's a finger, finger person.
Cat food dispenser might've lovin'.
Is in a jail near Bonnie?
Okay.
All right, well, we'll do that next time on Chibi Elden Ring.
Whoa!
I'm gonna go chill, feed the cats.
He is looking up like, hello?
If he didn't really eat this morning,
so she's probably hungry now.
Squish, squish, squish, squish, squish, squish, squish.
Squish the baby belly.
He he he he he.
What are you doing?
Um, in a cult Iris for the catana?
Do I have that?
I think I do have that.
Where, where would that be?
Like, I actually think I do have that.
Is this like, is this a shield the person from Grace, right?
Is it consumable?
Yeah.
Is that, is that it?
Yeah, baby!
Yippee!
I have it.
All right, we'll do that.
Oh, I'm gonna get ready for the Holocure stream.
Never played a Holocure before.
Well, there you go.
We killed Jory.
We killed some hippos.
We, you know, we got some, we got some,
got some scabadabada fragments.
Next time on Shibi Elden Ring,
Shibi is set on finding a set of armor in Catana.
Her track takes her to explore.
Will she find the armor?
Find out next time.
Bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce.
Yeah, but maybe we'll,
maybe I'll play some Eldering after Holocure.
Who knows?
Yeah.
All right, let me raid someone.
Let's see, let's see, let's see.
Will she sip Mesmer once more?
Let's give it e-shirts.
Let's see, let's see, let's see.
No, I don't want to look at Anna.
Please, just bring me to my level.
There we go.
Probably use the same thumbnail.
Do you guys like the thumbnail I made?
I love my thumbnail, what I mean?
I like my silly thumbnails.
Strony's doing a watch along.
Watch along, VV.
Florence, I, what?
When is she watching?
She's watching, I've never heard of that.
Bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce, bounce.
All right, since Strony, my love,
since she's gotten a second to raid her,
I don't want to wait an hour to raid her.
That, that weird lady.
But I hope you guys understand what I said
at the beginning of the stream and stuff.
Like, don't, I'm a Sino, taking a little break, chilling,
trying to avoid stressing myself out of things
and perpetuating things that I don't need to.
I care about you guys a lot.
Interaction will mostly be streamed and stuff.
You guys are lovely.
I kind of want to take a nap.
I might take a quick nappy poo.
Quick, quick little nappy, nappy nap.
After I feed Fia.
But yeah.
You still have to wait for the fansly stream.
Wah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
When that'll be?
I don't know.
Wah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Am I too, am I early through the stream?
Very early.
I'm about to leave.
So go, go sleep, Stroney.
But yes, you are sucking limbo forever, trapped.
Oh, it feels so good.
I love you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you for understanding.
No brain worms, okay?
I'm avoiding brain worms.
You're avoiding brain worms.
We're all happy.
Lem, lem, lem, lem, lem.
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
Let's be making out with your face.
Mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah.
You're on a wait, because you have a girlfriend.
Get out of here.
Get out.
I'm your only girlfriend.
Anyways.
Um, so I hope you guys, I hope you guys, I just turn around and put a gun at him and
I'm like, in hindsight, I think he was referring to me, but it's fine.
It's, it's, it's funny.
It's funnier for the memes.
Um, someone had a wife.
That's different.
I think.
I don't know.
I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll come up with an excuse why that was okay later.
Okay.
Bye.
Cause they had his Johnny, you'll see you in a little bit.